Benji's so obnoxious about his age like
us Benji's age and it's like he gets
weird and he it's a stick it's like you
can't ask the guy a straight question
well I think when he started with us he
came to us as an intern but he was an
intern age how old is he he won't admit
that he's 50 and I think he was 54 years
ago he's probably up 54 years old you're
gay how is he hiding his age that's the
reason why Benji had a book his own
ticket to go to LA because everybody had
to give like a license and Benji and he
won't tell you where he lives
he's got a whole thing going on is it
exhausting in a way with this cover-up
of your age I booked my own flight
because I wanted to have if I had to
change anything I didn't want have to go
through another person that's not my
book my own flow but a bit Benji stop
when I was an intern one of my first
tasks was to get you to fill out a form
for our office manager that needed your
birth date on it and you wouldn't do it
you made it impossible I had to chase
you around for three weeks and finally
ask somebody else to do it this is an
ongoing thing for years this is it new
is it really that embarrassing to be in
your 50s I will tell you when I when I
get there let's let's say I'm just
trying to find out why the shame and
your age is it the comedy thing that you
feel that you're an up-and-coming young
comedian and you'll be viewed as an
older man let's say you're correct I'm
saying you're not correct let's say you
were why why then what else would it be
why don't you then tell me why don't you
give out your age no I do give out my
age okay how old are you
48 oh okay all right
that's all right that's just not true if
you're lying why do you lie is what I'm
asking
well I would have to agree with you that
I'm lying to explain why I lie are you
lying are you a liar are you question
are you a liar no Benji all jokes aside
didn't you tell us you were 48 five
years ago for real yes I've always been
48 I've never changed that why the lie
don't joke about everybody
I'm asking a serious question why are
you lying okay I'll talk to the Benjy
puppet how will do you Benjy puppet I'm
25
oh okay are you lying if I was lying how
would you know when I'm lying if I say
that I'm lying then maybe I'm telling
the truth all right
don't thank you all right thanks bench
thank you
Benjy puppet okay I like Benjy I'm not
looking to ruin his life maybe he is
somebody like the FBI is looking for
he's probably abandoned a family right
he probably has a family out there that
you hunted him down for child support
[Laughter]